[Music]
On January 1st 1863 Abraham Lincoln
legally changed the status of over 3
million enslaved blacks across 10 States
from slave to free his Emancipation
Proclamation wasn't a law or
presidential decree it was an executive
order the framers of the American
Constitution made the power of the
executive order available to the
executive branch but what exactly is
this tool how does it work and what is
the extent of its power well an
executive order isn't a law but it can
carry the weight of one passing laws
involves a fairly lengthy process first
a member of Congress proposes a piece of
legislation in the form of a bill after
many committees and revisions if the
bill is approved by a majority of votes
in Congress that is both the House and
Senate the bill is then sent to the
president for signature if the president
signs the bill it then becomes a law an
executive order on the other hand is
something the president issues without
consultation or permission from Congress
they are however enforced like laws and
are subject to judicial review by the
court system to make sure they're within
the limits of the Constitution that
means the courts have the power to
invalidate any executive decisions that
they determine are an overreach of the
president in trying to assert power and
once the president leaves office if his
or her successor wants to eliminate the
executive order they can do so
so when does a president use an
executive order sometimes a president
feels the need to exert power without
working with Congress and in times of
crisis quick decisions can be justified
but most executive orders are not
responses to emergencies they're often
directed towards agencies in the federal
government in order to expand or
contract their power others determine
the extent to which legislation should
be enforced and sometimes a precedent
may use an executive order to clarify
and help implement a policy that needs
to be easily defined some of the most
famous executive orders have changed the
course of American history FDR issued an
executive order to establish the Works
Progress Administration which helped
build thousands of roads bridges and
parks throughout the country the WPA
also employed thousands of writers
painters sculptors and artists to create
works of art in public spaces
additionally Harry Truman used an
executive order to desegregate the Armed
Forces in 1948 and in 1965 Lyndon
Johnson signed an executive order to
establish requirements for non
discriminatory practices and hiring and
employment executive orders have often
been used in positive and inclusive ways
but they've also been used to exclude
and divide one of the most notable
examples being FDR's 1942 executive
order he gave the military authority to
target predominantly Japanese Americans
as well as German Americans and Italian
Americans in certain regions across the
country this executive order also
removed any or all of those people into
military zones was commonly known as
internment camps
beginning in the early 1960s each
president has issued roughly 300
executive orders but FDR issued over
3,500 at the other end of the spectrum
William Henry Harrison never issued an
executive order probably because his
presidency only lasted 31 days the US
Constitution is somewhat ambiguous on
the extent of the president's power
that's resulted in executive orders
expanding over time for instance since
Lyndon Johnson presidents have begun
issuing orders to create faith-based
initiatives establish federal agencies
and remove barriers for scientific
research there are checks and balances
in the US political system Congress can
pass laws to counteract executive orders
and judges can help them by deeming them
unconstitutional but in the time it
takes for those things to happen an
executive order can go into effect and
possibly change the course of history
for better or for worse
[Music]